well a different kind of love was
celebrated 40 years ago today yes
yes the wedding of prince charles and
princess diana oh and four decades later
the fascination is far from over
e.t actually spoke to diana's famous
dress designer as well as her younger
brother
about that historic day
[Applause]
the first moment of the day i remember
was going to see diana as she was
getting ready
in her wedding dress and makeup and
before that i was just her kid brother
really
and before that she was just my big
sister but then when i walked in that
day i thought my goodness
they've transformed her into i had to
say a very beautiful woman
750 million people around the world
watched live as lady diana spencer
became the princess of wales
diana francis wilt thou
have this man to thy wedded husband the
bride had just turned
20 years old her younger brother charles
spencer was just 17.
she seemed so poised and elegant
that wasn't really the diner i'd grown
up with she was much more exuberant and
alive than that
but it's i think it showed that she on
some level
accepted what was expected of her and
she did become
that day a sort of fairy tale princess
it took diana three and a half minutes
to walk down the aisle she was escorted
by her 57 year old father john
my father had quite a bad stroke a few
years before and we were worried that he
wouldn't actually
make it up the aisle but he managed to
take his daughter up the aisle so we're
all very proud of that
she may have seemed poised but diana
made a famous flub
saying her new husband's name out of
order
but was the spectacle all for show dino
told me initially that it was the worst
day of her life
because she just felt like she was a as
she said a sacrificial lamb at the same
time
she when she entered saint paul's
cathedral with all the cheering and
applause she saw prince charles and
love brimmed over in her heart so it was
very emotionally confusing day
she saw camilla parker bowles in the
congregation and she said to herself
well i hope that's all over with
another royal in attendance diana's
future sister-in-law
sarah ferguson we remember about that
day oh that's so sweet kevin no one's
asked me that
diana gave me the material to wear
and turquoise and it was beautiful she
loved me wearing turquoise
she was my best friend since she was 14
and i was
16 and it was the greatest
greatest i couldn't have a better seat
diana's silk wedding gown almost earned
more headlines than the ceremony itself
there were 10 000 pearls sewn into the
dress 300 feet of tulle in the petticoat
and another 450 feet of tulle in the
veil
the train was 25 feet long designed by
david and elizabeth emmanuel
the gown was wrinkled from being stuffed
into the tiny carriage
and its color was controversial at the
time
we decided to go ivory and and that in
itself we knew would be
unexpected because people were thinking
we would do a white dress
we were really guarding this secret with
our lives we didn't want anybody to see
it
she loved the dress she really did the
moment diana put on her dress for the
wedding was recreated in the crown
in real life diana had many fittings the
problem was that
donna lost a lot of weight during the
process so we cut out in the fabric and
had to keep taking it in
and so she tried it on many many times
the dress is now estimated to be worth
millions it has been loaned by prince
william and prince harry
and is now on display to the public at
kensington palace
after appearing on the buckingham palace
balcony the newlyweds posed for their
official wedding photographs
including this iconic shot which diana's
brother remembers being taken
i think there are 50 or 60 people in the
photograph and not many of them are used
to taking orders so the poor
photographer in the end just had to blow
a whistle and startle everyone and
that's when he got the sort of magical
shot
[Music]
you